i think the thing that people
misunderstand about success
is they're looking for the easiest way
to get there
winning is not about
the trophy and the accolades everybody
wants
the end result and they want to feel the
sugar and the the
the confetti and all that other stuff
but what you have to endure
to win no one wants to talk about
every minute you have an opportunity to
win life
and winning is a bunch of sprints within
a marathon
after you lose or when you get knocked
down
stay down there for a minute
understand why you lost other people win
because you win it isn't just about you
it's about being able to pull the team
when you have individuals that go out
and run marathons
you know if you compete at the highest
level and you're
a person that just runs marathon the
chances of you winning that marathon
are pretty much zero winning is not
supposed to be fair
life is not fair there's nothing that's
going to guarantee you
that when when you look in the mirror
you can lie and see what's on the
surface cannot lie what's going on
inside
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
tim grover and my take on his top 10
rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one expect
obstacles i think the thing that people
misunderstand
about success is
they're looking for the easiest way to
get that
you know and it's funny how many people
books have you read or i won't say
promoted but had on your show and
everybody goes
five easy steps 10 steps to greatness
yeah no eight steps to this and
those steps for success they're infinite
they are
infinite you cannot count them
it doesn't matter how long you've been
doing it those steps are constantly
shifting
you don't know if they're there
sometimes you have to trust that the
next step is going to be there when you
can't even see it
and sometimes when you step on that step
you go right into quicksand
but you got to be able to pull yourself
back out of it again
so everybody's looking for these steps
and there are no steps so steps
never never end and you just can't climb
steps
sometimes you got to crawl though those
steps and you finally get to the top
and everything shifts and you're at the
bottom it's crazy
all right what is that what does that
mean sometimes you're at the top and
then you're at the bottom again
well you may get to the top and you're
like i'm here
and then you look back down and you look
up again
you're actually on the first step you're
on the first step again
and where you thought was the top is not
even the top it's the beginning wow
it's literally the beginning of where
you're supposed to be
and that's when most people just quit it
i just like it just drives me crazy
because everybody's like
here look at i always people that i do
the interview with i always like to use
them as an example because people can
relate to that
all right you've been climbing steps for
how long to get to here
to get i mean since starting this it's
been over eight years but
the journey before then it was you know
decades to build myself to prepare
myself for this and now i feel like i'm
just getting started
right exactly so you have it right
exactly
so all the steps that you climbed just
to get started yeah
just to get started and people don't
want to talk about those steps
they don't want to talk about those
steps and how difficult those steps are
and how many steps that you stumbled on
and how many steps you didn't even see
and how many steps that people placed in
front of you when they pulled
and they pulled them off pulled away
people that you were very close to
people that you knew
right that people that you thought that
were like hey
these people actually have my back
except yeah they did have you back but
they were actually
pushing you down the steps yes no
and it's funny when you talk about those
things
or people talk about them they seem
surprised but you should know
that in that path all those things are
going to be there
they're going to be there rule number
two be willing to do it
again winning is not
about the trophy and the accolades
it's about the grind it's about the
obstacles
it's about the challenges it's about the
pain
that you endure along the way
for that 30 seconds
of being able to either stand on the
platform
be acknowledged by individuals that are
close to you
but when that happens
your mind has to immediately shift back
because now
you felt and tasted something
that you could only get through winning
are you willing to do it again rule
number three endure
winning is in all of us
we all want to win but the path people
take to get to winning
everybody wants the end result and they
want to feel the sugar and the
the the confetti and all that other
stuff
but what you have to endure to win no
one wants to talk about
and that's what really winning is about
because you spend more time
enduring it and being in a pla
and not in a good place and i wanted to
bring it out and say hey
no matter what you do in life where
you're at
this is what winning takes and it's in
all of us it's in all of us you find
wins
every single day rule number four
recognize your wins do you think anyone
can become a winner
winning isn't all of us that's what i
was saying listen
and we have wins every single moment
yeah and those are the steps that get us
a little closer to what we want we have
a stat we
every minute you have an opportunity to
win you really do
but with everything that went on in the
world in this past year
people forgot how to win people don't
even know what a win looks like anymore
what does it look like yeah people don't
even know like
and so many times a win just comes by
because there's a constant change
there's a constant shift
and now with the paradigm of way
everything is being handled now
you have to look at things completely
different everybody's waiting for
normal a win a win doesn't look like
what it used to look like anymore right
all right what does it look like now
what does it look like now for each
individual it's different
for each individual it's different for a
lot of individuals
it's just like getting out of that
routine that you were stuck in for so
long
and did the pandemic allow you to say
you know what
yeah i was in a routine but the routine
wasn't getting me anywhere i was in a
routine of comfort
and the pandemic put a lot of people in
a routine
that was very uncomfortable that they
weren't used to
they weren't you but it was a necessity
it was needed
you know people always wish for this
time during this
thing that happened i want to spend more
time with my family
and now they have it now you have it
okay
schools aren't doing a good job with
with educating my kids
now you're homeschooled all right i'd
love to work from the house
now you're doing it now now you're doing
it now you have all these things going
on that you wished you had
as you thought were wins and for some
people they were
and for others you're just like no
these were not these are not wins these
aren't
i do a lot of zoom stuff at home and i
got a
cat and i got a very lively dog and
you'll see the cat run right
right across the screen of course i
don't have little kids in the house
anymore
but trying to work and have them in the
background
asking for school help or you know
they're there on their bandwidth trying
to study in their school stuff
and winning became a distraction
it became a distraction and people were
trying to balance all these different
things and forgot
hey this is what my win is
that you need to recognize what that win
is now
and during the pandemic it's not getting
back to normal
it's getting beyond normal
figuring out what your next win is how
to
place it and how to continue to move
forward on that win
yeah because it's easy to talk about the
setbacks
because so many people can relate to
that that gave us a nice little comfort
thing everybody can use
the pandemic as an excuse yeah all right
and then you have other people that
thrive during that time they're like
i got i got to find out a new way to win
i got to find out like a real real new
way to win and you had some people that
really really won big during that time
absolutely they stepped up
they stepped up yes they stepped up they
saw the steps
and i was like okay
are these steps stable are they unstable
it doesn't matter i got a climber right
i got to climb them also if you want to
have more self-confidence and
self-belief i've designed a special
free training to help you do it the sign
says it can take up to 254 days of
consecutive action
to build a new habit and i want that for
you i want you to build the habit
of self belief so what i'm going to do
is email you every day
for 254 days a link to an
unlisted video that will shift your
belief forward
to get on it for free the link to join
is in the description below
the very first thing i do when i wake up
in the morning is i want to get my head
right i do this thing called priming
stop resisting i encourage you stop
resisting the natural flow of epic
performance
stop resisting the natural
seasons of life everything i didn't want
to do
is what got me to where i'm at today
rule number five sprint
every day life and winning is a bunch of
sprints within a marathon
you know it's a fact yeah a bunch of
sprints
within a marathon and you can't see the
end line like in a marathon you
know where the end line is in winning
that win that race may have an end line
but there's another start line right
after it yeah for people that are really
driven and this is just this is not
about money and this isn't about
fame this is about you could be winning
as a school teacher you'd be winning as
an entrepreneur you could be winning in
business you could be winning as
an athlete as a waiter whatever it is a
waitress whatever it is
it's that every single time you sprint
to that finish line
there's another start line that's coming
and that's why it never ends it's a
marathon that just keeps going
going and going and i try to tell people
listen i'm not an
avid runner i used to be in my much
younger days not avid i used to enjoy it
you see the times of the
the best marathons they're running
insane insane
they're basically sprinting they they're
basically they're they're sprinting
they are they are sprinting everyone
looks at the physical condition
are you mentally prepared to sprint
every single day
are you mentally prepared to sprint
every
single day and for how long because
somebody else is sprinting you don't
want them to get
what be what should be your win ends up
being somebody else's win
rule number six know how to lose
it's interesting that you said that i
know about winning the reason i know
so much about winning is because i've
had to deal with
so much losing that's interesting what
do you mean by that
everybody wants to win but in order to
know
how to win you got to
know how to lose because you're going to
lose more than you're going to win
but every time you lose what do you gain
from it
so every time i've lost people say you
got to jump right back
up you know get back right on your feet
again and i i disagree with that
after you lose or when you get knocked
down
stay down there for a minute
understand why you lost what were the
reasons
why are you down here why did you lose
why did you get knocked down
because if you just jump right back up
you're going to lose again
and again and you continue to lose the
same way so every time i lost
i stayed down for a second
minutes hours days
weeks but when i stood up
i was different i was smarter
and when i lost again i stayed down
i stood back up i was stronger
when i lost again i stayed down
how did i stand up again i was more
confident
lost again stood up
i was more resilient now you start
putting
the pieces that are necessary to win
over
and over and over again so if you lose
and you jump right back up and you
haven't really changed
i mean really really changed from that
loss
you're never going to learn from it and
you're never going to really
truly know the unforgiving
race to greatness because that's the
that's part of the unforgiving part
is the losing part that part is
unforgiving
rule number seven win in all arenas
you just don't win in one arena
you win in your sports you win in
business
you win in your personal life
other people win because you win
it isn't just about you it's about being
able to
pull the team and
show them what it feels like to win
what kind of feeling that gives and when
you win
your family wins when your family wins
you win when you win your friends win
the people that have supported you
every time michael played i always said
this
i said and i said this in the last dance
he would say these individuals are
giving me something
that's way more valuable
than the price of a ticket to giving me
their time
which is non-refundable
which is not you can't exchange it with
somebody else you can't take your ticket
and exchange it with another interview
these people are really giving me
their time whether they're at the arena
they're sitting in front of the tv
they're watching the news listening to
it on the radio back then
whatever whatever it may be
my accountability to myself and those
individuals
has to be at the highest level
has to be at the highest level because
they're doing something
that is so giving me something that's so
valuable
i have to yeah be at my best
i have to be at my best rule number
eight
rest at the end people
they look at winning and finishing
as the same those individuals that
you're talking about
they're just looking to finish they're
just looking to finish their career
they're like okay this is what i got
this nice house i'm finished over here i
made the nba or made the end of that
that's finishing and a lot of people to
that
they're like they feel like if they
finish they've won
these individuals it's a completely
different it's a completely different
level
so you have individuals that go out and
run marathons you know
if you compete at the highest level and
you're
a person that just runs marathon the
chances of you winning that marathon
are pretty much zero but you're going to
finish that marathon
but being able to finish that marathon
puts you in a mindset
to win at something else
so there's always what's next what's
next what's the next thing that's going
on you know we talk about what kobe one
of his biggest lines
is you know don't rest in the middle
rest at the end winners rest at the end
when you talk about fit people that just
want to finish
just what you said they rest in the
middle rule number nine
get in the race winning is not supposed
to be fair life is not fair
there's nothing that's going to
guarantee you that win
it's but the only thing that's going to
guarantee that loss
is if you don't get in this race how
many people and you talk about this all
the time
about the fears and the emotions and
like you know just
getting just going for it just like here
it is
look at yourself you've moved
three different times in probably the
last six months
for whatever reasons you've had all
right
and you've really packed up and moved
like here i'm going here i'm going here
you got people that won't move
themselves out of a chair
you've literally moved families lives
played and
there's literally a fear behind every
single one of those but there's no doubt
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips
is visit the person deep within when
they look in the mirror
they're just trying to see what's on the
surface but winning and losing wants to
know what's inside of you
it wants to know what makes you tick it
wants to know
what your desires are wants to know what
your ego is it wants to know what your
limitations
are it wants to know what your mindset
is it wants to know
everything about you because winning
does not lie when you look in the mirror
you can lie and see what's on the
surface you cannot lie what's going on
inside
and that's what people are not willing
to see the lies that are truly going on
inside of them that are not allowing
them to win
over and over sometimes even win once
you have to look winning requires you to
go so
far deep inside yourself it's way beyond
the surface it's way beyond
internal it's going to a place that
a lot of people haven't visited in a
long long time because they're afraid
to visit that person because when they
visit that person
they don't know who that person is
anymore now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you just get inspired you
watch a video you get motivated amazing
the science says you have a 35 chance of
actually doing something actually
following through
that believe nation is not enough that
is not you
not now not anymore not today but when
you get inspired and then you create a
specific plan of action for what you're
going to do
that number jumps to 91 chance of you
following through
and when you commit publicly to others
like leaving a comment
in this video it jumps to 95
so the question of the day is your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and maybe next week i'll profile you in
the book kobe said
he said winning is everything it's
everything
all right and you sit here and you talk
talk to mike
whatever kobe would say mike would have
to one-up them
because they're still the competition
never stops it's
always about what's next what can i what
can i win
more at you know both those individuals
you know obviously kobe's not with us
anymore but both those individuals
the competition and the desire
and the feeling of winning even though
they were done with playing
manifested into something else you know
mj the most successful sneaker brand out
there
right owning a team tequila business
um in the sports gambling business he's
in
all those things he's in all those
things
all right so the competition never stops
with kobe
it was like i'm gonna win an oscar go
out and win an oscar
writing children's writing children's
book he was literally
his goal he would his plan
was to take over hollywood he was like i
owned
l.a on the basketball court
and now i want to own
la he wanted to take that was his
winning thing take the basketball out of
it
everyone knows i own la on the
basketball court
and we talked about this he goes own la
own la and if you look at the paths he
was going through
that's what he was doing that's what he
was
that was his that was his next
definition
of winning when i started studying
everyone says oh you're going to be a
gym teacher i said no
i said i'm going to work with
professional athletes i knew what i
wanted to do i said i'm going to work
with
i'm going to work with professional
athletes so that was my
that was the goal i set in my mind and i
just said hey
that that's going to take a place in my
head that's the only thing that i want
to do and i got to figure out a way
i got to figure out a way to get there
so i studied and learned my craft
better than anybody else did i start
with the professional athletes no
after i graduate i went to work in a
local health club
really i knew how i knew everything from
a book standpoint but
still you got to know how to apply it
okay so i
you know worked with anybody i could any
these are not pros these aren't pros i'm
talking about housewives i'm talking
about
individuals that just want to get in
just want to get in shape people that
have had
injuries from different sports kids
anybody
just kind of developing programs putting
implementing what i've
learned and actually being able to apply
it and once i started to
look at that craft i said okay now i'm
starting to figure out
how to how to actually apply this stuff
and how to use it and put the
formulas together and put the workouts
together and do all these different
things i mean stuff that
they're doing now from a workout
standpoint i was doing 30 years ago wow
i was doing that stuff is new to you no
i mean some of this stuff is you i it's
different i stay on top of it right all
right i got to continue to learn
you know continue to be uh better myself
so i can better my athletes better my
craft
but it's a different it's just a
different way of doing the same
different way of doing the same thing
right now there's a lot more resources a
lot more education a lot more testing
available
back then you kind of had to just figure
it out because
a lot of individuals now okay especially
in this generation not only from a
training standpoint but from a knowledge
standpoint they're jumping from
one thing to another you know they're
using this trainer this week they're
using another trainer next week
you know they're they're using this
person as a mentor on youtube then
they're using this person over here
okay and they're getting all this
conflicting information
okay you gotta you gotta master
what you're going to master okay you
have to fit you have to figure it out
too many people are jumping from place
to place to place
michael kobe all these individuals they
mastered
one aspect of the game when they
mastered that aspect of the game
then they moved to another aspect of the
game when people become successful
okay they always say i don't do that
anymore well what do you mean you don't
do that anymore
you should do that and then something
what do you mean you don't do that
anymore the most successful people
know and can do it all all right
can do it all okay michael you know what
he never
when he played he would go around pick
up the towels in the gym
after practice put the basketball really
put the basket put the basketball
michael jordan michael jordan
colby did the same thing put the
basketballs away all right
do it just do whatever is what i was
supposed to do he that
he practice uh got his own game gear
together
you know now people have these stylists
and so forth they put their clothes
together michael put his own stuff
together
he's just like handled his own tickets
kobe did the same thing so it's just
like
hey just because i'm now the superstar
all right
i still wanted i still have to do the
things that
got me there because it reminds me wow
of what i did and what it took to get to
to get to this level everyone's going to
hit adversity yep
okay everyone's going to hit adversity
it's how you
deal with adversity and the key word is
you not letting somebody
else deal with that adversity you have
to deal with that adversity
and how you deal with it are you going
to fight through it or are you going to
curl up and just roll over into the
corner it's going to pretty much
determine how the rest of your
development from a mental standpoint
is going to carry you you know people
talk about this uh
people talk about this all the time you
know losing bill's character
okay well how much character do you need
seriously
all right you know you want to keep
losing and losing
listen i'd rather have a person win who
has a little bit
who has a little bit of character okay
who's a little nuts and a person that
loses all the time
and he's got he's got great character at
some point you got to start
you got to start winning you can't
always look for other people to help you
other people got their own problems they
got their own [ __ ] they got to deal with
they're trying to achieve their own
goals they're will they are willing to
assist
but after a while okay if you're
constantly
looking for a system constantly looking
for help it's it's
on you your failure and your success
is on you well you have a lot of players
you go dealing in sports you have a lot
of people in business
they're successful for themselves yeah
okay or the team they put up great
numbers
but the team never wins all right
you know in business when the owner or
the ceo when he wins
if he's a cleaner everybody in that
business from the top
person all the way down to the last
person they
all win when sports if you can
you bring out the best out of all your
teammates you elevate
not only your teammates you you elevate
the equipment matter
you elevate the equipment manager the
staff the people you have
no idea the people that handle the
tickets everybody's game
is elevated because they have to because
the cleaner is not going to come down to
your level
you got to come up to theirs so when
you're choosing somebody when you choose
somebody to listen to
and you choose somebody to learn from
and you choose a business partner
you choose a client they got to be as
crazy
and they got to be as as you are that's
how you get success
that's how you know you're going to be
able to push that individual that's how
you know that relationship is going to
last
you know people talk about in business
or think oh you got to find a balance
you got to find that person you know
if you're one way you got to find a
person that's the other way no that's
that's pulling you away from how you
want to do things and how
if you're intense the next person i want
is to be as
super super intense now those people
around you they got to be smarter than
you are right
you don't want to surround yourself with
people that if you're the smartest
person in the room you need to get more
people in the room
sure okay you should not walk into the
room and ever be the smartest person in
there
okay the people around you have to be
much smarter or at least
in certain things you may have an
expertise in one thing
but that other individual better have an
expertise that's
beyond yours in something in something
else
right but from the mind standpoint you
know
mj was just as [ __ ] up as i was
kobe was just as [ __ ] up as i was from
from being the best okay i wanted to be
the best at what i do
they wanted to be the best at what they
do all right so
it was an attraction it's an attraction
and those are the people that allow you
to push them and allow them to they
understand they want to get they want to
get better you know they don't need to
be motivated okay
they're like you tell them hey that's so
interesting they're not they're not
hiring you to come motivate me
nobody want it as bad as you they want
the best of the best
already want it more than anybody else
there's a reason they're the best
you know we we talked about this earlier
at lunch they're the ones that are
show up to practice early okay they're
the ones taking the extra shots they're
the ones doing the wind sprints at the
end they're the ones
you know getting treatment taking care
of their body they're showing up
they're showing up on off days i mean
you're changing you're sending the guys
home you're saying you got to go home
you got to go home
you got you got a little you got to you
got to tell them to leave you don't have
to tell them to show up
you got to tell them to leave that that
that that's enough you know you have
people in your office so you look at it
you know how many employees do you have
now we got 4 200 agents
4 200 agents okay out of 4 200 agents
okay
if you put them all in all in the room
okay and you were able to put them all
in one shop together
all right and say your hours were nine
to five okay
you'd have 4 200 people in here from
nine from nine to five o'clock
from five o'clock after five o'clock you
may have 500
after seven o'clock you may have two
hundred
after nine o'clock you may have five and
then guess what at the end of the day
there's gonna be one light left on
maybe two yours and somebody else's that
person's as [ __ ]
as you are
right but you can count on that
individual you can count on that
individual
you spend more time here let's so we're
both workout guys we like to go to the
we like
we like to go to the gym all right how
many times
have you seen people in the gym they
spend more time on their playlist
taking pictures doing stuff instead of
getting their work instead of getting
their workout done
so true it's just like you know and
here's the thing all right
you're a very intense person i can tell
right okay i'm a very intense person
all right we value our time yes okay how
do you get
results in the gym it isn't about
spending two to three hours working out
people say i spent three hours
you didn't spend three hours by time you
pulled into the parking lot
that by the time you changed got some
breakfast put your workout clothes on
talked to eight people did all that
stuff you were there for you were there
for three hours
you did you you did you you did your
three hours no intensity
yeah all right all right people talk
about hey
you know you post a couple of workout
things you see your buff guy or your
next you're in great shape
people say ed i want to look i want to
look like you
all right they don't see what it takes
to look like you not only in the gym
outside of the gym the intensity that's
there
you're in the gym and i'm assuming you
work out with music you had some
headphones on
you got to get a certain amount of stuff
done in a certain amount of time
or you're in this intensive somebody
comes up to you yeah
okay and you don't want to be rude to
them so you die you take your headphones
off they ask you a question they want to
take a picture with you oh i recognize
you from so and so on
all right and then the question is how
do i get to look like well the one way
you get to look like me is leave me that
for long
and start hitting start hitting the
weight start start lifting
it's the intensity that you have it has
to be in
everything you do you have to be an
intense person
in your workouts the way you the way you
eat
okay that's that's intensity how do how
do you fuel up your metabolism rates so
you're burning these calories so you can
get that definition that's intense
that's an
intensity how do you get to be
successful you know oh man he
he or she he's so intense no you know
what he and she
that's how you're supposed to be you're
at a different level
right and that's why i said the
intensity is so
it's so important it's what really
separates those individuals
and you can't get into that zone and you
can't get
arms and abs like that
or you can't do it unless you have that
intensity and you're willing to block
out the distractions
we have so much access now to
information
yep it's literally at our fingertips you
know
everything okay why are more individuals
doing less you're right because they're
easily distracted
relentless is more than just a mindset
it's a skill
set it's a mindset it's a way to kick we
talk about kick
and taking names well when you're
relentless you've kicked so much
you can't remember all the names because
it becomes irrelevant the name that they
remember
is your name that's what relentless is
being about it's not about
others it's about yourself it's about
taking yourself to a level
that only few people can achieve the
mindset is completely
different it's about capturing other
people's hearts
and not letting them go
it's learning to step on their throat
it's about killing the competition your
fiercest competitors are cutthroat
individuals
all they want to do is win and they want
to win
over and over again it's not just a
one-time
thing success is repeated many many
times
you can have a skill set to do a lot of
things okay you can train you can read a
manual you can do all these different
things
but a skill set only works if you have
that mindset
everyone talks about i got passion i got
inner drive
you know what passion inner drive is
it's absolutely
nothing unless there's a action a
relentless
action that follows it and if you have
that relentless action that follows your
passion
that follows that inner drive you have
then you get that end result
other than that you just have a bunch of
emotions that mean
nothing being relentless isn't something
that you're born with
when you're born the doctor doesn't
stamp on this person is going to be
tough this one's going to be relentless
this person is going to be soft
it's something that's in everybody all
right it can be taught it can be
learned but you have to take the
necessary steps
if you're good at something you can be
great at it if you're great at something
you can be unstoppable at it there's
always a next level
so don't let anybody tell you that it
cannot be learned and it cannot be
taught
it can be and relentless teaches you how
and that's
the bottom line how many times have you
watched sports and they said
the person's thinking too much stop
thinking yeah
stop thinking just go out just go out
and play what happens when you tell an
individual to stop thinking what's the
first thing they do
they start thinking exactly do you know
how many
hours and years of preparation
go into not being able to not to think
about something
okay it takes years
and years and years of doing the same
thing over and over and over again
okay learn how not to think not to
think wow to be able to take a to take a
reaction
and turn it into a reflex that's what
the greatest
can do most people react to things okay
the greatest it's it's an instinct it's
it's impulsive it's innate it becomes a
it becomes a reflex you know we talk
about this listen
trust your instincts that's what closers
do you know what cleaners do their
instincts trust them
i got this i'll give you a great example
about that and we'll pick up the other
thing
all right doug collins coach of the
bulls
is drawing up this play okay last second
play he's drawn
it's the cleveland play the one he beat
uh right yep so he's drawing up all he's
drawing up this play
all this other stuff he's over he races
it michael turns around said hey
give me the ball get the [ __ ] out the
way
in the timeout yeah after the time like
you know before doggies goes give me the
ball get the [ __ ] out of the way
okay that's that's the don't think
okay that's the point where hey listen
my instincts trust me give me the ball
just get the hell out the way i'm
winning this game
i'm winning this game but that
game-winning shot
wasn't made there it was made many years
before
in the you know in the dark gym by
himself with somebody rebounding the
ball whether it was me or somebody else
shooting that same shot over and over
and
over and over again saying if i get to
this spot
i don't care if there's 10 hands in
front of me
if i get to this spot the shot's going
in because i've done it
over and over again just for a second
because this just
blew my mind is your dad they come from
india right yes
right and your dad um
you're in the cab you just get here
you're in there
yep and my mom's already here okay
establish herself as a nurse
and well my dad
it was easier for my it was easier for
my mom to get her license here
as a nurse practitioner that was for my
dad to get his license as a as a doctor
all right an md and he wasn't able to
get it
wasn't able to get the license we still
came over
we're sitting in the cab and he's
counting the money and the meter gets to
i forget what the number was and my dad
tells a cab driver
stop and you're a little boy right a
little boy yeah i was four years old
he said stop and we're like what's going
on
and my dad goes hey listen we're in a
new country i want you to enjoy the
scenery
so we get out we grab all the luggage
excuse me get real emotional
it's awesome
and we're walking down the street
[Music]
that's awesome brother
you got it yeah we're walking down the
street with his luggage
and he's showing us the different
scenery and so forth
never knew he didn't have any more money
in his pocket wow
wow amazing but he got us here got you
there that's so
powerful you imagine that little boy
walking down that street turns out to be
you and amazing your dad sewing those
seeds into you
and there's moments like that that
define you as long as you remember them
they can define
you both ways you can look at it and say
you know what
you can use that as an excuse my dad
came to this country he didn't have any
money he never gave me anything he never
did this and people do that
or you can look at it and say he gave us
everything well you know what we in the
book relentless we talk about the don't
think concept
your skills are so finely good at what
you do whether it's trading
making business decisions playing
basketball that you know the net if you
do fail at something
it's just this little stumbling block
the next time you're going to succeed
because you've done it
over and over over again not only
physically but your mental preparation
the thing that makes individuals really
really
special who are that great is they're
always looking for that competitive edge
so it's interesting to see how
a champion in sports how it relates to
a champion in business it's the same
mindset
it's about winning the battles
continuing to improve
learning news ways to stay ahead uh stay
ahead of the game
clarity is what gives you the idea
of success being able to close those
deals
when you can see and you can think and
you can react
with a clear mind and your take your
emotions
out of it you're in that zone getting
the deal is just a it's just a byproduct
and the minute you get the deal you're
already thinking about what's next
when you want to excel at something what
must you have did i just hear somebody
say passion in the audience
you know what passion is passion is an
emotion
it's an emotion without an action
passion will get you
nowhere inner drive will get you nowhere
unless you
act on it you have to act on your
passion
you have to act on your inner drive
don't let those feelings
stay inside of you you got to know what
to do with them you got to know how to
make them work
in order to get what you want don't keep
it inside knowing that you're the best
at what you
do and you've done all your homework to
get to that point
relentless is about trusting your
instincts but the only way you can trust
your
instincts is if you've done your
homework and your skill is so finely
tuned at whatever you do
you have people in sports you have the
role players and they're trying to step
out and be superstars and i just i
always tell them i said
you got to think about winning first
all right if the team wins you'll get
paid
if the team doesn't win you will not get
paid
all right the bottom line is the
end result just like when you guys close
a deal
not only do you win everybody underneath
you who helps you close the deal
the company it all ties in together
decide commit act
succeed repeat the one thing that all
the greats have in common
is they sweat the small stuff they pay
very very close attention to every
detail
michael used to sweat the details so
much in his basketball game that carried
on into his
personal life the suit had to match the
car he was driving that particular day
but what those details allowed him to do
wants to put him in the zone to be the
best basketball player
on that given night well the dark side
is something that's in
everybody but it's a situation that
you have to control the dark side if it
controls you that's when things start
to go real real bad that's when you have
a tendency to go to the
to what i call the other side but if you
harness the fuel that's from that dark
side whether
it's anger whether it's fear and turn
that into positive fuel
it'll help you really succeed at
whatever you're trying to do a great
leader knows how to push buttons how to
push the buttons of different people
i totally disagree with that philosophy
100 percent
all right i don't want to have somebody
to have that much control over me where
they're pushing my buttons
as a great leader okay what i do with my
clients
is i pull their buttons
and then i teach them in certain
situations
to know when to push their own buttons
well you have to keep yourself focused
on whatever
your ultimate goal is their stumble
their stumbling blocks all the way
people get laid off you have a bad game
you get traded from a team that you
don't want to be with but if your goal
and your focus remains the same that hey
this is going to happen and i know i
have the skills and i have the knowledge
and have the instincts to dig myself out
of this hole
you will dig yourself out of the hole
you have to control the situation don't
let the situation control you
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there